so we just want to play a little game
with you called this or that okay do you
think you express yourself better
through song lyrics or screenplay song
lyrics because you're not gonna go in
there and do a song by myself what a
movie you need over 100 people to really
pull it off so I say song lyrics more in
control as a rapper or producer rapper
do you see yourself more as an actor or
a movie star movie star I like it if you
wanted to Doug diversify in acting would
you choose a romantic comedy or a period
piece period piece would you yeah
romantic comedies of the boring if you
had to do an album in another genre
would you pick country or pop I guess
country
well I country there's more wrong my
music is wrong it's not really poppy so
how do you cruise down the street now in
a minivan or in a 6fo 6fo graduating to
the minivan better buddy cop movie
co-star Snoop Dogg or Kevin Hart Kevin
Hart awesome thank you so much that was
really fun no problem all the new
dealers in Atlanta are getting supplied
through Antonio Pope in Miami you need
to get me something on this guy two days
tops we're gonna team together and fix
this put me in on a James I'm like half
cop half Puma I'm getting your ass
you